[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in louis riddick the former
defensive back and he's the analyst for
monday night football next week monday
night football lions at the packers the
ravens next game sunday night hosting
the chiefs the raiders next game at the
steelers on sunday and louis joins us
now louis if i missed the game and you
were trying to sum it up
could you sum it up
um
yeah just that you couldn't put any kind
of word limitation on me though
you know i mean it'd be
it'd be a little bit longer of a of a
summary but what i mean damn you saw i
mean what a wild night a little this
wild night
um
i think the raiders for once
really
as long as they don't have anything
unforeseen happen from an injury
perspective or from a covered
perspective i think they have
the makings of a team especially on the
defensive side
that could really give them a
respectable level of play unlike any
defense they've had since maybe john
came back yeah and i think that's a big
difference
and i think with the with the ravens
i still think i think they're going to
be fine they were playing so
so much so you know
at a deficit because of not knowing what
the running back room would actually
look like on game day
the offensive line hadn't played very
much during the pre-season got you know
they have a new right tackle in the
middle of the waiver who you saw really
struggled they know now
just what they're gonna have to possibly
do with that
um
but i still think they're gonna be okay
because really i mean they're
that game could have went either way so
i think they're gonna be fine but i
think i think the raiders could really
could really have a decent team they
really could but the the key is going to
be that defense
is derek carr the guy
yeah
i've always believed that and you know
what
the the the debate with him or
surrounding him
for his entire career has always been
something that's kind of puzzled me a
little bit
and i know you know and this started
even before like he even got to oakland
i mean there was always been this you
know at first it was just a ridiculous
well you know his brother wasn't very
good
and it's like well who who cares i mean
what does that have to do with him
and then it was well since he struggled
with some situations as far as uh
throwing the football against pressure
at fresno he's gonna struggle with it in
the nfl nah that but see though some of
those things followed him when he got
when he went to the pros but if you look
at his career objectively
look at how he stacks up against some of
the best throwers in the nfl
in critical situations whether it be
fourth quarter comebacks
uh third down completion percentage
um
completing you know completion
percentage in the red zone or or passer
rating in the red zone this guy is right
up he's top five top eight
throughout the the course of his career
and in particular
last year
and i think he's he's someone who right
now is so
he's so comfortable with what john is
doing from an offensive perspective
he knows everything about that offense
to the point where it's like they both
will tell you he could probably teach it
as well as john can teach it
that i think you're going to see him
play
you see him play the best football he's
played yet
and he's going to take guys like henry
ruggs and take guys like brian edwards
who was
basically the hero last night
and he's going to make them better
players so that's really i think what's
next for derek not just how high how
much further he can take his game
statistically
but how much better he can make everyone
around him how much he can elevate the
people around him because that's truly
why we really
you know when it really comes down to it
that's how we really measure greatness
at the quarterback position is
you know numbers are numbers and i get
it and some numbers have more importance
than others but it's really about how
much better you make your team and how
much better do you do you make your the
guys on offense as far as elevating
their level of play and he realizes that
i asked him that specific question when
we talked to them
before the monday night game
and he's very aware of it and i thought
you saw it happen last night
and i think you're going to continue to
see it happen
it's not very often when i could take a
highlight reel of a quarterback i could
give you
like three or four or five plays
and it all happened in one game but i
could also give you low lights of three
or four plays
and lamar jackson had both of those last
night
um
what do you make of his performance last
night
i think
even though
he wouldn't say that uh
he felt any added pressure
as far as having to
play above and beyond
his own standard of greatness that he's
already set but the truth of the matter
is he played last night like like
someone who knew that or who felt like i
had to do something even more
spectacular than what my normal standard
is and
he may have at certain points in time
gotten careless as far as
ball security especially when
he was running taking off trying to pick
up some extra yardage i mean you saw i
mean the two
the two crucial turnovers that the
raiders defense forced late in that game
we're in situations where
you know he's the primary ball carrier
he's in traffic and there and
and
that i mean it just it cost him it cost
him
i think
i think he'll he'll learn from that
he'll learn from that and that won't
happen you know with a consistent level
of uh
of occurrence as
one he watches the tape from last night
two the offense itself really finds its
identity and really starts to develop
some cohesion because it doesn't have
many half of these guys have been on
they haven't really been on the field
together all preseason long for
different reasons starting off lamar
missing time because of kovan the
offensive line you know they've been
shuffling people around especially in
between you know from guard to guard and
then they didn't play it played very
much together
uh you know all the running back
injuries obviously
the injuries that wide receiver with
rashad bateman and miles boykin not even
really not really being available to him
so i think as they all start to kind of
like get it together from a health
perspective and start to have some time
to practice together and greg roman
offensive coordinator has an idea of
exactly how he can best utilize everyone
i think you'll see lamar's mentality
shift from
i have to do everything to just
okay now i can just utilize what's
around me but last night
there's no question he felt like he had
to do more
than what
than what was really necessary and it
cost him crucial moments
were you ever in a locker room where you
knew your starting quarterback was not
the right quarterback for you like the
bears situation that andy dalton is
there
but there's part of that locker room
that probably says
put in justin fields he's the best guy
here how does that work in the locker
room
yeah i've never
i've never been in that kind of
situation with um
with the quarterback position in
particular
but i mean you can you can definitely
just from a
from a team perspective i haven't been
part of teams my whole life you can
understand how
in the bears locker room there's
probably there's there's definitely
going to be those who feel as though
justin
needs to be in there right now
there's probably a certain set you know
a certain part of the locker room that's
a little bit louder than others as far
as making that point known
and with every loss that they
you know that they continue to rack up
and
with every
touchdown pass that justin continues to
throw in or run for it both in practice
and in games like he did the other night
against the rams
that
you know that silence
not really silent but that kind of vocal
minority is going to become a vocal
majority
and matt's got to be very careful and
make sure he has his finger on the pulse
of that
because if he he's got to make sure this
this season doesn't get away from him
from his locker room kind of like you
know fracturing and splintering to the
point where he can't recover it
and then you know try and make a move to
justin before you know and it's too late
yeah he's got to be definitely you
definitely got to be careful with that
yeah i just wonder if matt nagy has that
much
i'm not going to say confidence in his
job but it feels like he
if you were desperate then you'd put in
justin fields then you would attach
yourself to your rookie quarterback and
say well we don't want to break up that
relationship
and i don't know if
i think they play the lions maybe in
week five and i was wondering if if
maybe that's enough time justin fields
gets in for a little bit sprinkle him in
there and then all of a sudden you
unveil him in a in a game against a you
know sub-standard team but trying to
figure out that logic with a coach who's
on the hot seat you get your rookie
quarterback it almost felt like they
went with the rookie quarterback because
that was going to make may you know mean
that the coach and gm were going to keep
their jobs for a little while longer
yeah i mean you know when you when you
try and really
you know predict how this would you know
potentially play out yeah i could see
where you feel that way and
and how most people would feel that way
and quite honestly i
i felt you know even knowing matt as
well as i do
i always i thought that you know at some
point in time like sooner rather than
later obviously he would turn to him too
because he didn't
you know he he's he's a realist he
understands that
you know things are on the line and that
you know obviously if you go with a
young quarterback it could
wind up giving you more time as far as
your you know the review surrounding
your job status is concerned and that
maybe he would like rush that along
sooner rather than later
and he has pushed back against that
theory right from the get-go dan
he has said numerous times and i believe
that he doesn't care about his his job
status this is really about the short
and the long-term
development and then sustainability of
justin fields
of his career that he's trying to
safeguard the young man's career he
doesn't really care what happens to him
meaning if he gets fired he's going to
do the right thing he's going to do
right by the kid
and
that's
and
look i mean most people feel though and
the whole city of chicago feels at least
just put him in there and quite honestly
you know even being as close as i am to
matt i feel he should put him in there
but he really does want to see what andy
dalton can do he really does feel as
though justin obviously doesn't have
there's something that's not making him
comfortable right now to the point where
he would just throw him in there
especially given the deficiencies that
this offense has
and look i respect the hell out of him
for doing it that way because the the
the scrutiny and the pressure that's
being put on him right now to play that
kid
i mean you know it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable and he won't he won't rush
it until he feels as though that's the
best thing for the kid and the heck with
his own job status and i respect that
great broadcast last night with the guys
we appreciate you joining us as always
and uh have fun uh next week in green
bay
you bet thank you that's louis riddick
former nfl defensive back and uh in the
monday night booth with steve levy and
brian gracie we'll take a break our play
of the day is up next here on the dan
patrick show